when historians look back at this time
500 years from now
they will put a Breaking Point right
where we build a space elevator
this is pre-space and this was
post
this is an entire new Society
Everything Changes
[Music]
imagine simply climbing a cable into
space
no rocket
just press the up button and you're
there
[Music]
the concept is known as the space
elevator
not only could it significantly change
how we leave planet Earth but it could
also completely transform Humanity's
relationship with space
and there are scientists who think and
could have already built it
[Music]
ideas of a space elevator type device
extend as far back as the 19th century
but these ideas struggle to advance
beyond the Realms of Science Fiction
as we continue to rely on tried and
tested methods of getting into space
right now we've got Rockets
they use a lot of fuel they take a lot
of fuel to get up into space they have
to carry fuel to lift the fuel
to lift them into space if you want to
go to geosynchronous orbit it's millions
of dollars per pound if you want to go
to the moon or Mars
it's expensive with the space elevator
we reduce the cost of getting into space
too
dollars per pound
[Music]
so how does the space elevator even work
the basic idea is a cable would be
pulled taut thanks to a counterweight it
stays vertical because the counterweight
is thrown outward by the Earth's
rotation and the base is held down by
gravity early ideas suggested building a
cable from Earth up into space but the
materials needed to withstand such
enormous weight don't exist
physicist Bradley Edwards breathed new
life into the theory I've been working
on the space elevator along with a
number of other
Space Systems and new technologies for a
better part of 30 some years I searched
for years to find a reason why we
couldn't build a space elevator there
was no reason
the problem with earlier versions of the
space elevator was we just didn't have a
way to build the cable that was needed
to maintain a space elevator and Brad
came up with an Innovative twist looking
into the future on where carbon
nanotubes might go in terms of strength
carbon nanotubes are something of a
super material despite their tiny size
they're theoretically stronger than
things like Kevlar or graphene
Brad Edwards suggested launching a
rocket which would carry the carbon
nanotube cable
one end of the cable would then be
dropped back towards Earth
the cable will be light enough and
strong enough to build just a thin
ribbon which robots could climb to build
more ribbon
eventually becoming strong enough to
carry heavy payloads such as solar
panels satellites and even tourists
so what about the cost of carbon
nanotubes is this the biggest hurdle
literally in our system it costs us
about a dollar a gram and we need about
a thousand tons to build the first space
elevator but when you talk about
building the space elevator there for a
total of eight billion dollars we easily
spend that money launching satellites
it's not that expensive
there's an estimated 128 million objects
smaller than a centimeter orbiting the
Earth along with another 900 000 that
measure one to ten centimeters
all with the potential to cause
significant damage
Brad Edwards concept would see a space
elevator mounted to a Mobile Oil
rig-like structure to dodge any
dangerous material
it's really hard to imagine that you
could have a space elevator that could
survive the number of collisions that
one would expect over the lifetime of a
space elevator and you know if the
ribbon's cut you're having a bad day
again we're talking about ribbon three
feet wide thinnest paper if you break
the top part off
the the counterweight what happens is
the ribbon starts to come down it breaks
at the bottom and the entire
ribbon flies out into space never to be
seen again
[Music]
I would love to be proven wrong
if we had a space elevator it would be
awesome it would be Paradigm changing we
can colonize the moon the Mars we can go
to the asteroids cheaply and we can mine
them for
minerals metals that we're running out
of now here on Earth it's changed from
back in
1998 it was science fiction you know
capturing asteroids bringing them in
building large cables and now we've we
have it and
we probably could have started building
it 10 years ago
[Music]